you know the saying don't do the crime
if you can't do the time well what if
you didn't actually commit a crime
what if they sent you to jail for being
broke it happens and more often than you
think
they're called debtors prisons it's
basically when you're tried in debtors
court for not being able to pay court
fees where a court fees they can be
anything from a traffic violation to
failure to appear in court for that
speeding ticket but increasingly their
fees for the criminal justice system
itself in over 40 states costs of a DNA
or drug tests parole a public defender
even jail time can fall to the supposed
offender it's even got a name offender
funded justice if you can't pay you go
to jail all while your debts increase I
spoke to Sam Brooke of the Southern
Poverty Law Center who told me about a
50 year old woman who couldn't afford
car insurance so she got ticket after
ticket for driving on a suspended
license she of course couldn't pay those
tickets either and eventually racked up
so many fines that she owed $2,700 but
since there was no public transportation
in her town she had no other choice
eventually she decided to lose the car
and just walk five miles to work still
though she was sentenced to 30 days in
prison the dish's cycle that happens is
people get caught in the system and
really get trapped in the system but it
gets worse
because private companies are getting in
on the action especially after the 2008
financial crisis cities and states and
counties are increasingly outsourcing
these cases to private firms to cut
costs we're called private probation
companies what they really are is
they're effectively glorified debt
collectors they're they are usually
simply there to try to help collect the
fines of cops owed and particularly
trying to help collect it from
individuals who otherwise can't afford
to pay it
Brooke calls this a moneymaker for
states and cities like Ferguson Missouri
Ferguson's second largest source of
income was from court fines and fees the
DOJ is 2015 civil rights report says the
city
more focused on revenue than public
safety needs but how is this even legal
especially when the 14th amendment made
it unconstitutional to imprison someone
who couldn't pay their debts and when
the Supreme Court doubled down on that
in 1983 saying that you couldn't be sent
to jail or sent back to jail if you
couldn't pay a court fine but in the
over a thousand debtor courts that are
around the country judges often slap
offenders with fines or jail time
without considering whether that person
is capable of pain according to Human
Rights Watch most the poor people that
end up in these courts don't know their
rights don't have proper legal defense
and are often given sentences within
minutes minutes that could mean months
or even years in jail the clear
injustice of this confounded debtors
court system is not going on challenge
though 11 people in Ferguson are suing
the police for coercion holding them for
unpaid fines and the Southern Poverty
Law Center the ACLU and others have all
filed suits on behalf of plaintiffs most
of whom are african-american and live in
a South what we're really concerned
about here is that individuals are
attempting to profit off of the justice
system and to perverting it from what
should be a system of justice into a
system of really a two-tiered process
where the rich are fine but those who
can't afford to pay are actually being
punished even even more greatly so there
you have it
American justice probably at its least
finest and you might think well that
makes sense you're locking up more
criminals so of course there's less
crime out there on the streets happening
and some extent you're right the brennan
center for justice